What does it take to break a bone?
Like, really…
Could I do it with my bare hands?!
Hello there skeletal-based humans!
Amy here for DNews.
Recently it came out that during the filming
of the latest Star Wars movie, a hydraulic
door broke Harrison Ford’s leg.
This got us wondering: how much force does
it take to break a bone?
As it turns out that question is a lot more
complicated than it sounds.
Adults have 206 bones that come in a lot of
shapes and sizes, so some bones are going
to be a lot easier to break than others.
The largest bone in your body, your femur
or thigh bone, is a lot harder to break than
the long slender clavicle, or collarbone,
which one of the more commonly broken bones.
Part of this has to do with the of muscle
around a bone that supports the bone and absorbs
some of the impact from a hit.
Your femur encased in all your leg meat, and
that can take more of a hit than your rib.
Dr Cindy Bir of the University of Southern
California estimates that a force of 3,300
newtons has a 1 in 4 chance of cracking the
average person’s rib, while their femur
typically takes more force to break: around
4,000 newtons.
There isn’t a set number for what force
will break a bone like a rib because how the
force is applied makes a difference.
A blow perpendicular to the bone is going
to do more damage than when that same force
is applied almost parallel, and that’s because
of how bones are built.
Your bones are actually made up of two types
of bone tissue: cancellous bone and cortical
bone.
Cancellous bone is the spongy inner material
and usually contains red bone marrow that
makes red blood cells.
Cortical bone, also called compact bone, makes
up the outside.
It’s dense, hard, stiff, and accounts for
80% of your skeleton’s mass.
This outer layer is made up of columns of
of collagen and calcium phosphate, like bundles
of twigs.
Collagen provides the soft framework in the
bones and calcium phosphate adds the strength.
Because these columns run vertically, they
give your bones strength down their length.
Bones are great at taking compressing forces
like when you jump but can’t deal too well
with shear forces like when someone hits you
with a car.
Certain people might also just have stronger
bones, depending on their diet, age, and lifestyle.
Your bones are dynamic: they’re constantly
being broken down in a process called resorption,
and rebuilt.
Because a big component of them is calcium,
a diet low in calcium means your bones will
probably be a bit more brittle.
And just like with muscle, putting stress
on your bones through exercise can make them
stronger.
That’s why astronauts come back from space
with reduced bone density: floating around
up there means their bones aren’t getting
the same stress they would on earth.
But even if your diet and exercise routines
are great, there’s no fighting age.
Our bones reach a peak density around age
30 and then begin to decline when the resorption
of bone happens faster than formation.
Eventually this can lead to osteoporosis,
a condition where bones are weaker and can
fracture more easily, sometimes even under
normal use.
In the US, an estimated 55% of people over
50 have osteoporosis.
If you’re a fan of 360 and VR videos, Seeker
has launched our brand new Seeker VR channel
perfect for watching your favorite videos
using the YouTube app or VR device.
So put on your headphones and get ready to
experience videos in a whole new way!
So, when I said the human body has 206 bones,
I bet some of you said dudes can have 207.
Way to be immature, and no they can’t.
But other animals can!
Laci talks about penis bones here.
Have you ever broken a bone?